Adam Sandler is a mutual friend of ours
now you did AirHeads with him back in
the day I did and you both have had such
longevity now Adam's like never stopped
no like I don't know how he just has his
never stop for a second I've taken
pauses in my life particularly when I
had children what were the pauses you
took was being a parent a big part of
stepping back for a while because that
wasn't for me yes I mean that's a given
I you only want to do what's what's best
for your kids
um and in my case I needed to
reevaluate the journey that I was on I
needed to attend some physical issues
with bones and muscles you know we're
all growing older and um it it also
means you're growing a little bit wiser
too I wanted to work smart instead of
work hard